hi in this video we're going to talk
about how tyroid hormones work at a
molecular level thyroid hormones are
secreted from the thyroid gland which is
situated on the top of the trachea so if
we look at the thyroid gland and take a
cross-section of the thyroid gland we
would see that there are several
follicles which are filled with colloid
like substances miss : except substances
are nothing but the thyroid hormones
when the thyroid gland is stimulated
from by TSH which is tyroid stimulating
hormone coming from the pituitary then
the thyroid gland secretes t4 which is
tigh Roxon and triiodothyronine t3 these
are the principal thyroid hormones this
thyroid hormones has widespread role in
various aspects of human physiology and
metabolism for example thyroid hormones
increases the cardiac output increase
ventilation rate and it increases the
metabolic rate of an individual now
tired hormones potentiate the effects of
catecholamines that means it augments
the flight-or-fight response in females
thyroid hormone is found to thicken the
endometrium lining and overall in case
of metabolism it has been seen that
thyroid hormones increase the catabolism
of protein and carbohydrates so let's
look at in the molecular level how these
things are orchestrated and that is a
discussion of today's topic like here is
a sale which is going to be responding
to the thyroid hormone so thyroid
hormone receptor is present in this cell
so where is the thyroid hormone receptor
present unlike any other cell type where
the receptor is present on the cell
surface tyroid hormone receptor is
located in the nucleus already bound in
the DNA but when the begin is not bound
it is bound to a repressor
upon binding the ligand the repressor is
removed and it binds to activators such
that transcriptional activation can take
place let's look at this whole
transcriptional activation in bit more
details so here is thyroid hormone
receptor which works like a heterodimer
it has a R
sorry and a thyroid hormone receptor so
thyroid hormone receptor binds to the
thyroid hormone which is principally t3
t3 is the activated form and t4 gets
converted to t3 in order to bind to this
to this receptor and this receptor with
its DNA binding domain binds to the
response element now thyroid response
element are distinct from any other
steroid hormone binding site and this
sequence specificity is determined by
the zinc finger motives present in the
DNA binding domain so obviously thyroid
hormone receptors would definitely bind
to the thyroid response element and not
any other random DNA sequences and that
governs the specificity now under normal
circumstances no transcriptional
activation take place and why is so
because when the ligand is not bound in
this situation the thyroid hormone
receptor is bound to a repressor complex
which recruits Aged acts or histone
deacetylase histone deacetylase has
profound effect on the chromatin and it
it allows the chromatin to be in a
compact compacted state as a result the
transcription factor the polymerase
cannot access the DNA and no gene
transcription takes place
but while the ligand is bound in this
situation the repressor complex gets
ubiquity violated and degraded as a
result that activator complex now can
bind to the thyroid hormone receptor now
the co-activators recruit many other
things such as nucleosome remodeling
complex system methyl transferase and
histone acetyl transferase together all
of these make the chromatic more
accessible and less compact as a result
polymerase and several transcription
factor can access the chromatin which
allows gene transcription but wait what
genes are transcribed by the thyroid
hormone receptor or the thyroid hormone
and thyroid hormone receptor complex the
genes that are transcribed by thyroid
hormone and thyroid hormone receptor
complex are widespread and this is an
overall summary and it is dependent upon
cell type as well in different cell
types it transcribed different type of
genes but its overall summary like
sodium potassium
ATPase gluconeogenic enzyme glucose
transporters respiratory enzymes myosin
heavy chain beta adrenergic receptor all
of these things are products of or all
of these things are transcribed by
thyroid hormone receptor now we have to
understand these molecules that are
listed here are diverse
so the physiological effect orchestrated
by these molecules would be also diverse
we're gonna take a specific example and
try to understand earlier we have
already talked about that the fight or
flight response is augmented by thyroid
hormone how is so let's say you are you
are running from a mad dog who is trying
to bite you and you really need to run
fast otherwise you would be bitten right
so your skeletal muscle need to move at
very high your skeletal muscle need to
contract at very high rate and that's
why your muscles need glucose but after
the point of time your glucose would be
depleted and how your muscle would
rapidly get glucose right in this
situation adrenaline helps adrenaline
receptors or beta adrenergic receptors
which are present on the muscle cell now
this beta adrenergic receptor in a
g-protein coupled receptor signaling
allow the activation of the enzymes
which would lead to glycogenolysis and
by glycogenolysis with the breakdown of
glycogen your muscle would receive
ready-made supply of glucose which could
be utilized to generate ATP and that
would allow muscle contraction now let's
resume back to the thyroid hormone and
how thyroid hormone can augment this
process it turns out that thyroid
hormone receptor on hormone receptors
and thyroid hormone response element are
present in the muscle cells especially
the skeletal muscle cells now thyroid
hormones can actually bind to these
receptors elements hormone response
elements and transcribe beta adrenergic
receptor and myosin heavy chain now beta
adrenergic receptor augments the
activity of the fight-or-flight response
by allowing more adrenaline binding to
these receptors
and moreover things more myosin heavy
chain are transcribed by the action of
thyroid hormone
now the muscle contraction can be even
more forceful this is how thyroid
hormone work hand in hand with the
flight-or-fight system and saves our
body from any kind of damage or our
flight-or-fight response are augmented
by this kind of hormonal mechanism I
hope this video was informative if you
like this video give it a big thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you